the following program contains flashing
images
violence and images of dead bodies
from the battlefields of the middle east
to the streets of europe
islamic state now threatens us worldwide
isis wants to be in all the places at
once because it wants to increase
disorder globally
in a world exclusive sky news uncovered
the existence of
thousands of islamic state files
they've been recruiting globally as well
so you've got some of the best most
brilliant minds
you know this is really an enterprise
goal now we show not only the scale of
the organization's
international recruitment network
but the true nature of the threat it
poses
they're planning on being involved in
terrorist attacks abroad no matter what
santa erfer in southern turkey
an ancient trading post with traditional
links to syria
over the past 18 months i've been
traveling in and out of the city
gathering intelligence on the civil war
in syria
above all i've been coming here to learn
about one group in particular
islamic state six weeks ago i had a
meeting with one of the many defectors
now fleeing is
he told me his name was abu hamid he
spoke of his utter disillusion with the
organization
i want to say to the people on the
inside of the organization
the group is a lie it is not islam there
is nothing that ever follows the sharia
or islam
it's far from islam
but hamid is no ordinary defector
he has risked his life to steal one of
islamic state's most closely
guarded secrets
he handed me thousands of computer files
compiled
by their high command
the most comprehensive intelligence leak
in the organization's history
the files are detailed entry forms for
foreign fighters going back
three years to 2012.
they contain the dates of when the
fighters entered and the biographical
details of volunteers from over 50
countries
who travel to fight the holy war in iraq
and syria
these include names telephone numbers
and crucially details
of those who recruited them in the first
place it is
an intelligence gold mine
is this information so important that it
could actually
destroy dash god willing if we will give
it to those who will use it of course
and if you were to tell someone how to
use it what would you tell them
this intelligence information of course
needs to be used
it should be with people who fight
against islamic state
with people who really want to work
against islamic state
not taken by those who wish to return it
to the organization
our analysis of the files and interviews
with former islamic state members
and people with close links still to the
group show that this was an organization
running a sophisticated global
recruitment operation
from the very start and in a stark
warning to western governments
it's clear now that from the very
beginning they were training
foreign fighters to carry out terror
attacks on our streets
fundamentally it's a terrorist
organization that believes itself
is the heart of the clash of
civilizations that's happening with the
west at the moment
and i think what's happened now and
what's changed is it seems to decide to
be much more active
in bringing that clash of civilizations
to the countries it's fighting against
we've spent many weeks analyzing the
files we've now gained
a fresh insight into how islamic state
operates
the files enable us not only to look at
islamic states history in a new light
but also to gauge the extent of its
global terror network
i've come here to the town of jarabas
even though we're still in turkey only a
few residents remain
the majority driven away by the presence
of islamic state only a few hundred
meters away
across the border in syria
over the past three years the border
crossing here at durables
has played a crucial role in the rapid
and bloody rise of the world's most
feared terrorist organization
the islamic state files showed the
places where they crossed from turkey
into syria hot spots if you like of the
terror groups movements now this is the
town of jarablas
it remains an islamic state town even
now
time and again it is mentioned by the
recruits as a place where they came
to fight in syria and to be trained
crucially though despite the efforts of
the turkish authorities
it remains a crossing point even now
the files show that from april 2013
onwards there was a steady flow of
foreign fighters crossing into syria
from all over the world but what drew
them to the country in the first place
the answer lies with this man abu bakr
al-baghdadi
baghdadi was a leader of one of the many
iraqi sunni insurgency groups
that had sprung up after the u.s led
invasion in 2003
a decade later with the chaos continuing
in iraq and the civil war escalating in
syria
he announced the establishment of a
radical new organization
he called it islamic state of iraq and
sham
isis
it was really meant to be the beacon and
the home for muslims
everywhere and he specifically made
calls for those who felt alienated or
those who felt like they weren't
part of the west or like westerners were
fighting against him
and that message actually resonated with
individuals
outside of the arab world and outside of
the muslim majority world
the files revealed that among the very
first volunteers to answer the call of
baghdadi was 25 year old
abdul majeed abdul bari
[Music]
in many respects abdul barry fitted the
profile of a westerner who felt
alienated within his
own community he kind of typifies
a kind of a type of person we seem to be
seeing being drawn to fight
alongside isis and alongside other
extremist groups as well
he comes from west london he seems to be
on the periphery of sort of gang
communities there um his father was a
known
uh extremist
[Music]
he was involved in sort of gang activity
in west london he was a
part-time aspirant rapper who was sort
of making some name for himself as a
figure in the sort of rap community
around london
i'm reaching out to you lord i know you
hear me i hope you near me
i could feel the lack of love it was
fascinating he could look at his sort of
twitter timeline
at a certain point and see the moment of
which he actually started to tell people
please start taking my music videos down
because i now reject that life
and i've in fact discovered islam and
islam doesn't speak for these things
[Music]
in july of 2013 abdelbarry swapped the
streets of west london
for the syrian desert
three years on his whereabouts remain
unknown and rumors
that he has deserted the organization
are unconfirmed
in the months that followed baghdadi's
announcement the newly proclaimed isis
movement
made rapid gains across both syria and
iraq
and as the fighting continued so did the
need for increasing numbers of foreign
recruits to realize the dream
of establishing a lasting islamic state
and an increasingly large number of
those volunteers
were coming from britain
in april 2013 the formation of a new
radical jihadist movement
isis had been announced from that
moment thousands of fighters had flopped
from all over the world to join the
cause
and a high proportion of these were
british
in october of that year our files show
that five volunteers from portsmouth
set out to join isis
the pompey crew as they became known
included muhammad hamadur rahman
mashadur chaudhary and muhammad mehti
hassan
all of bangladeshi ethnic origin
when we see the clustering of fighters
so example a group of british fighters
joining isis early on
what that tells us is that there's
likely a network there of recruitment of
kinship
of affiliation where potential foreign
fighters aren't just going on their own
but are also talking to their friends
talking to
individuals that they know and once
they've actually traveled to syria
for example to join the islamic state
they're likely turning back to their
home networks
and facilitating others who might be
considering that journey
from analyzing the files we know that
this was exactly what happened with the
portsmouth crew
on each of their arrival forms they had
registered this man abu abdul rahman
al-butani
as their sponsor we now know he is this
man
iftakar german also from portsmouth who
had joined isis
back in may 2013.
you're dealing with organizations here
that are secretive networks
you know that are worried constantly
about being compromised and penetrated
by intelligence agencies and others
so within that there is a sort of
vetting that has to go on
you know you have to know who it is
who's coming to join you and be able to
sort of piece together where they've
come from and part of that is having a
sponsor
so you have someone who kind of takes
responsibility for you or somebody can
vouch for you within the organization
jarman was an enthusiastic user of
social media such as twitter and
instagram and skype and he kept in
constant contact with the group
back home in portsmouth
in turn they asked him for practical
advice about making the journey and
crossing into syria
one of the men asked jarman please keep
me in your prayers
and help to get across with all the
necessary arrangements
after weeks of messaging they were ready
this cctv records them walking through
gatwick airport
to catch a flight to turkey
and a month later they were joined by a
further five fighters from cardiff
they included riyad khan seen here in an
islamic state recruitment video
this is a message to the brothers who
stayed behind
you need to ask yourselves what prevents
you from coming to the land of israel
what prevents you from joining the ranks
of the mujahideen those that spill the
blood to raise the
hell to raise the right
the process of turning idealistic young
westerners into battle ready jihadis
must have taken intensive training over
time
i wanted to try and piece together what
happened to the foreign fighters
after they had traveled from here in
turkey over the border
back in sanur i made contact with yet
another islamic state defector
who had recently fled syria
and he was able to provide some insight
into what happened to the raw recruits
we have met many foreign fighters of
various nationalities
they usually go straight away to attend
a sharia training camp
after that a fighting training camp
after which they would be dispatched to
various fronts
some of them would get sent to the
administrations or security sections
all foreign fighters have to surrender
their passports and ideas on arrival
muhammad's evidence about the training
is backed up by documents contained
within the is files
these are not entry forms but the
records of those
who have graduated from camps after
extensive military training
in all 475 fighters are listed
from 30 nationalities including british
french belgians
german swedes and canadians
from 2014 onwards the foreign recruits
were sent from their bases in syria
over the border into iraq
the fighters by now highly trained and
motivated launched a series of carefully
coordinated ground assaults
the foreign fighters are usually a lot
more ideological than the local fighters
and as a result they're usually uh more
fearsome
they take more risks in battle and
therefore provides you know
greater rewards you know the more risk
the more reward on the battlefield
and therefore it helps them out in many
ways it also allows them to have sort of
this more
hard-line aspect of their ideology that
can be pushed always
because the foreign fighters are there
whereas the locals might be a little bit
more pragmatic it's their own home
country
one by one islamic state managed to
secure towns and villages in anbar
province against an increasingly
demoralized
iraqi army the suffocates were
scared to meet death and did not have
the nerve
to continue the fight
by june they were within striking
distance of iraq's second biggest city
mosul it was now time
for more close and personal battles
i specifically work to intimidate and to
degrade the iraqi security forces
by blowing up their houses by releasing
frightening execution videos by
killing influential individuals within
mosul and
in other nearby towns and that was all
part of an effort to soften that target
so that when the time came it could use
its sanctuary within syria
to actually push through and conduct the
splits maneuver
that made it seem like isis came out of
nowhere but actually was the result
of several years of intentional and
phased planning
[Music]
but it was here in june 2014 that the
first phase of islamic states
military campaign reached its climax
supported now by
large numbers of battle-hardened foreign
fighters they overran
large parts of northern iraq and
surrounded the city of
mosul when they attacked its center the
iraqi army
simply fled
would now proclaim a new momentous era
for the umma and the entire world
three weeks after the city's capture abu
bakr al-baghdadi
rose to address the faithful just over a
year
after he promised the formation of a
caliphate he formally announced its
arrival
this is the basis of the religion a book
that guides a sword that aids indeed
your brothers were blessed
with victory by allah and we're blessed
with consolidation after long years of
jihad
and patience
but the new caliphate is more than a
geographical area
under the control of strict sharia law
it's also a fully functioning
administration capable of collecting
taxes
with established schools and hospitals
and running a network of farms to feed
the expanding population
understanding that isis's primary aim
had been to establish a fully
functioning state
sheds new light on the information
contained in the entry forms
it explains why they go into such detail
in asking recruits
about their previous occupations and
experience
putting down somebody's former
occupation it allows the islamic state
to assess
what kind of skills the individual might
have they want to bring in people with
you know certain types of skills whether
administrative whether it's doctors
whether it's engineers
and others as well because these are key
aspects of helping to build this state
because it's not just about
you know fighting and killing your
enemies but also building something up
too
but around the same time as the formal
establishment of the caliphate
the first clues began to emerge of
isis's more wide-ranging
and sinister ambitions
a month after baghdadi's triumphant
announcement this man
junaid hussein listed in our files
arrived in syria he was an individual
who was very good
at i.t and computers and so he helped
sort of spur on the organization's
um cyber caliphate group which is sort
of organization which tri
claimed to try to do take down attacks
sort of around the world of sort of
hacking websites trying to pull
information from places
do all sorts of disruptive things like
that he was very active across social
media
and he was very active in talking to a
lot of people and what we subsequently
have is evidence of him talking to an
awful lot of people in the west
telling them to launch attacks and in
some cases giving them direction of how
to actually do it
one of the people who contacted junaid
has saying is this man
who we are calling faisal
i first came across janet hussein on
twitter on a twitter page called bakia
shout out
and the sole purpose of this twitter
page is to advertise jihadis
once they've been suspended to help them
gain new followers
and i noticed that janae was popping up
there daily so i went on to his profile
and from there i saw the account was
able to generate up to a thousand
followers within a couple of hours
within a few hours of establishing
contact with janae to say faisal began
to establish
a relationship he asked
what sort of operation do you want to do
i said well i'm in london what's
available
so he said okay perfect you're in the
heart of the crusader army and we can
hit them hard from there
hussein's next step was to send over a
set of instructions
he sent me a manual which guided me step
by step on how to create the bomb
and i noticed at the end it said to
cause even more damage
put rat poison into the bomb which will
make the kaffar
the disbelievers bleed slowly internally
and then finally a message detailing the
target
for the lethal device
he specified a location which was the
armed forces day parade
and he told me once the bomb was built
i want you to go straight into the
middle of the crowd
press the button imagine 3 000 nails
glued inside
and the outside when it explodes the
nails travel faster than sound in every
direction
in june 2015 islamic state cyber
terrorist unit
instructed one of their followers in
london to plant a bomb in the crowd
celebrating armed forces day
the operation was planned and directed
by the head of the unit
janae hussein what janae didn't know
was that all his conversations were
being monitored by me
janae desaim was passing on bomb-making
instructions to someone we had recruited
with the sole aim of penetrating and
exposing
his digital terror network
posing now as a female his undercover
work led him directly to this woman
former punk rocker turned is recruiter
sally jones
who is now in a relationship with jenade
he messaged me back saying talk to my
wife sally jones
and once again she first started by
asking me what do you want to do
i said i wanted to do something to hurt
the kaffar in the country
and she said do you reckon you could be
ready for this event
and once i opened the link it was the vj
commemorations
and after seeing who was going to be
there it was the royal family
she had planned to attack the royal
family in the uk
from the very earliest stages of our
contact with hussein and jones
we'd kept scotland yard's anti-terror
squad fully informed
four months later janae hussain who was
already known to both british and
american intelligence
was killed in one of the many targeted
drone strikes against key
islamic state figures
hussein's death may have been a setback
but his online presence was evident
of a new phase in islamic state's terror
campaign
i would suspect that when you sort of
announce yourself as the state
that's probably the moment at which
maybe the ideology of the organization
would have maybe shifted
a little bit more into that direction
well we are a state and we are a state
that's at war
and if we're a state that's at war we
have to fight back against
those who are fighting against us and
use the means that are at our disposal
three months after hussein's death i
began picking up stories of specialist
is training camps
in and around their stronghold of raqqa
in syria
once again the trail led to santa air in
southern turkey
and it was here that i was able to
collect some extra ordinary footage
smuggled across the border
in all over 15 hours of recorded video
some of it so technical
and frankly bizarre that it was not
immediately apparent
what we were actually looking at
this for example was some form of
remote-controlled car
put together in a workshop from parts
scavenged from across the devastated
city
it was only when we showed it to an
explosives expert
that it was possible to understand the
significance of what we were dealing
with
this is basically a car bomb that can be
delivered
remotely without a human being this is
effectively you know
the the drone of the car bombs
this mannequin is to be placed inside
the car
so it will effectively make the
the target the security of the target
think that there's a human being in that
car
what's most chilling about this
mannequin device
is the level of ingenuity that's gone
into it
they've created something to to try and
do
some of the most advanced security
detection systems
the mannequin is coated in wire and
wrapped with foil to distribute heat
a self-adjusting thermostat will bring
the mannequin to the same
temperature as a human body
lasers are attached to the head to
create parts
if the vehicle is scanned with any type
of heat detector it will emit the
signature
of a human being chris hunter was
familiar with some of the technology
but his greatest concern was how it
could be replicated by sleeper cells
abroad
these guys can almost trial this sort of
thing in a war zone
which pretty much matches those high
levels of security
and then if it works they can teach the
people that are coming back here to do
jihad
and teach them a way to improvise it
over here you'd be talking about
high value targets critical national
infrastructure targets
things like nuclear power stations
things like government buildings
ministries that sort of thing
you know in the united kingdom
buckingham palace um
the houses of parliament number 10.
throughout the footage were more
examples that islamic state
was taking the lessons and technology of
the battlefield
and adapting them for a new type of
warfare
this radio control device is
particularly interesting
this is something that i first came
across
from material i saw in chechnya where
chechen separatists were attacking the
russian troops
this particular weapon um is quite a lot
more advanced
not only does it provide you um you know
a level of sophistication in terms of
your radio controlled bomb
but actually you can use it to monitor
other airwaves as well
and air traffic and that sort of thing
so if we saw this
integrated with the rocket system that
we've seen in the footage
if we saw it integrated with a normal
bomb you know you could potentially have
something like this
outside heathrow you could be listening
to the air traffic
and then you could fire it off at the
optimum time
what is striking about the footage is
that many of the trainers and the
designers
make no effort at all to disguise
themselves
this man one of the most hands-on is
turkish
some of the instructors were iraqi with
military experience
and we identified men from syria tudisia
egypt
pakistan sudan and somalia undergoing
training
to take abroad so you've got you know
the top weapons engineers you've got the
top
physicists the top electronics engineers
explosive chemist
mythologists you know ballistics guys
and
they now have been recruited into this
organization
and not only have they now got this very
high level of technical expertise
but they've now been recruiting globally
as well so you've got some of the best
most brilliant minds
you know the most technically adept
people coming from foreign countries as
well
and the idea is that if they send them
back to the west the impact of a
terrorist attack
in the west is significantly greater
than the impact of an attack in syria
our experts analysis was corroborated by
the defector who had risked everything
to smuggle out the weapons laboratory
video
according to what we were told these
training videos were meant to train
people
outside syria inside syria they train
publicly anyway
the training program is meant for europe
and to cause
huge damage the program is meant to
target
a large number of people in more than
one location
it wasn't just meant for iraq or syria
the problem for the west was that this
new generation of terrorists
had already arrived
foreign fighters are an incredible asset
for isis the organization
not only uses it for its claim to be a
global caliphate
but it also enables isis to more easily
send individuals back into europe to
take advantage of an already strained
system
that's now dealing with a migrant crisis
to try to let individuals slip back in
at some point during 2015 a group of
three men traveled out of syria
and made their way to paris
it's hard to quantify just how many
fighters have ghosted their way into
europe
but we do now know the names of some of
these from the islamic state files
twenty-four-year-old food mohammed agad
was a native frenchman
born in strasbourg
his file recorded his name as abu sayyad
al-franzi
and that he had joined the organization
in 2013.
like so many westerners who joined
islamic state nobody saw it coming
this is he was a boy who never caused
any trouble
he led an extremely normal life he was
close to his family
and particularly to his mother he was
successful he was happy
he was a boy who didn't attract any
attention he fitted in
there was never a problem with fred
during his time in syria he was in
regular contact with his mother
but then suddenly he went off radar
none of his family had any idea he was
back on french soil
in the autumn of 2015 a group of at
least a dozen is terrorists
was hiding out in paris
they included 24 year old fued muhammad
agad
originally from strasbourg
also undercover in the city was another
frenchman
sammy amimor who had at one time worked
in paris as a bus driver
very little is recorded on his file
other than he had chosen to be known by
the islamic state name
of amino sami alfranzi
the third member of the team was omar
ishmael mustafa
a former petty criminal from the
outskirts of the city
he too provided no further biographical
details on his islamic state entry file
other than his adopted name of ishmael
omar mustafa
alfranzi
we now know that these three were part
of a team of at least a dozen men almost
certainly more
who'd been dispatched from syria on a
specific mission
it was a sophisticated operation that
required obtaining an
arsenal of semi-automatic weapons and
bob making equipment
as well as gathering intelligence and
scouting targets
while staying one step ahead of europe's
security services
finally on november the 13th 2015
they were ready
it is now 10 o'clock you're watching sky
news live as we
update you with this breaking news from
paris
[Music]
reports that hostages as we say being
held at the
city's bataclan concert hall
when the terror cell struck the results
were devastating
armed with assault rifles hand grenades
and suicide belts they attacked six
locations
here in paris it was the worst loss of
life
on french soil since world war ii
western authorities
absolutely underestimated the extent and
intent
of isis's terror campaign the foreign
fighter problem had been discussed quite
at length as we saw isis declare its
caliphate and as we saw
an unprecedented number of fighters
actually go and travel to join iraq in
syria
but it was primarily discussed as
something that would happen far in the
future
as a threat that wasn't quite here yet
and now the pieces are starting to link
together
the target of the three-man squad whose
names are contained within the islamic
state files
was here the bataclan theater
when they start to shoot really it it
looks like fire cracks or something like
that or something you know going
uh light broken or something like that
and
when this there is few seconds
between the moment they start and the
the moment where they stop the music
and to be honest when they stop the
music they'll switch on the light
and then at this moment when you see the
musician just throw it away their their
instrument and their all the things you
say it's not normal
some things happen because they could
see it so
and does this this this whole moment the
the encounter with the terrorist does it
does it live with you all the time
do you think about it all the time yeah
but there is
several steps there there is the attacks
there is the moment where we
were hide hidden in between the seats
and then you have
silence and shoot screaming silence
shoot stream etc
[Music]
while making their way to the rooftop to
escape benoit and his brother came face
to face with the terrorists
my brother recognized this guy in the
underground
he saw him yeah exactly and and yeah
definitely
this one this one asked me to close the
door
all three of the bataclan attackers blew
themselves up with suicide vests making
it all but impossible at first
to confirm their identities
but the french authority's task was made
easier thanks to a telephone message
from iraq
to the mother of one of the bombers
when she received the message from
fred's wife she rang me straight away to
say
it's horrible i received a message
saying my son is dead
yesterday or the day before as a martyr
with his friend
there were the attacks at the bataclan
i'm worried it was him
please look into it and without the
mother
we could never have identified
now know how food's islamic state bride
was able to contact his mother
he had included her contact details on
his original registration form
when he arrived in 2013.
it's a chilling reminder of the
terrorist organization's
ruthless bureaucratic efficiency
in all seven terrorists died in the
attacks on paris but other members of
the cell were still at large
one of these was a 35 year old algerian
national
who was operating 300 kilometers away in
brussels
his name was mohammed belcade his file
shows that he had visited spain
germany and france and that he had
entered syria in april 2014.
it is recorded on his entry file that he
had chosen to be a suicide bomber
according to online islamic state
propaganda belkade was a seasoned jihadi
fighter
he took part in some of the fiercest
fighting in syria against the assad
regime
including this battle for a
strategically vital military
[Music]
base its subsequent capture
led to a series of well-documented
atrocities against those troops loyal to
the government
we're here in the 17th division military
base just outside the city of araka
and we're here with the soldiers of
bashad you can see them now
digging their own graves in the very
place where they were stationed
[Laughter]
belcade was traveling around belgium
using a fake identity card in the name
of samia bouzid
four days after the attacks in paris his
identity card was used to transfer
750 euros to the cousin of this man
abdul hamid abaoud
armed with clues such as these
investigators began closing in
on the terror cell and in march french
and belgian officers began investigating
a number of addresses in brussels
when the police located and raided this
safe house their intelligence
was incomplete they expected to find it
empty instead
they encountered a heavily armed
muhammad bell cade
in the firefight that followed four
officers were injured before belcade
himself
was killed
inside the house the belgian police
found an islamic state flag
11 kalashnikov ammunition loaders and a
large
cache of ammunition
a week later what was left of the
terrorist cell struck again
first at brussels airport
and then at malbec metro station
isis is executing a campaign to
encourage and then also direct and
resource attacks on the west and it's
not only to punish those who are acting
against it as part of the us-led
anti-isis coalition in iraq and syria
isis also has a more insidious campaign
which is its campaign to polarize and
destabilize
the west and the organization has
written about this extensively it has a
concept called
destroying the gray zone so isis hopes
that frequent
constant attacks in its name will
actually encourage european states and
societies
to lash back against their own muslim
populations
the past six months have seen a series
of military setbacks for islamic state
on the battlefield
they've lost territory in strongholds in
syria including the city of palmyra
during that time i traveled to iraq
where a coalition of kurdish peshmerga
and iraqi regular troops are starting to
go on the offensive
for the first time in two years
a few weeks ago the iraqi army began
operation conquest it's supported by the
united states and basically the plan is
to clear out villages around mosul
before
an assault on the city some are hoping
that this will be the end
or at least the beginning of the end of
islamic states so-called caliphate
initially some believe that these
setbacks on the battlefield were an
immediate catalyst for the attacks on
europe
but a few days later on our way back
from iraq we received the latest batch
of leak material
from our sources in raqqa these confirm
the worst fears of many in the western
intelligence community
that islamic state have been playing the
long game
the infiltration of terrorist cells into
the west has not been going on
for just a few months but for years
the documents never seen before are
handwritten orders from islamic state
headquarters in raqqa
for a terrorist cell travelling out of
syria and updated november 2014.
they request that fighters are divided
into four groups as part of an operation
codenamed break the siege sending them
over the turkish border to be deployed
in infidel countries
this is a reply to the earlier letter it
says
we have compliant with your instructions
breaking the siege
refers to the citadel that needs to be
broken
and what we mean by that is the european
countries
these are the strongholds and each group
is given a specific role
the documents are the final piece in the
jigsaw of our 18-month investigation
that has involved intelligence from a
series of defectors
undercover work penetrating the digital
network
and now the revelation of the secrets of
its files
that finally makes it possible to
understand the true nature of islamic
state
both in the middle east and now in the
west
isis terror campaign is not new it has
two
grand strategic objectives the first is
to expand its caliphate to include all
historically muslim lands and the second
is to provoke and win an apocalyptic war
with the west
i would suspect that the ambition to
launch those sorts of attacks will not
have gone away
but i will argue probably as a result of
the success of them you'll see a desire
to do that
again
they're deadly and they're determined
and
they don't seem to be prepared to stop
at any point
i think they'll stop at nothing